we're asked to graph the function f of x
is equal to the principal square root of
0.5 x
minus 1. and to graph it we're just
going to sample some points some x
values that are within the domain of
this function this function definition
and see what the function is equal to
for those x values and then we can
connect the dots and see what the curve
might look like so let me do a little
table here
and so i'm going to pick some x values
and i'm going to figure out what the the
f of x values are given those x values
and actually i'm going to do something
in between because i want to have nice
clean numbers i want to pick x values
that are nice clean integers and i want
to get f of x values that are nice clean
integers so i'm going to be a little bit
more careful in what x values i pick i
want to pick x values so that this part
of this part of the expression this part
of the function definition ends up being
ends up being an integer and if this
needs to be an integer then what's
underneath the radical 0.5 x that needs
to be a perfect square so actually let
me make another column right over here
just to make our our math a little bit
cleaner
just to make our math a little bit
cleaner you could pick just arbitrary x
points you could pick x to be one two
three just go like that but if on some
of those you might get strange radicals
over here which would be hard for us to
to graph without a calculator so let's
try so let me write over here what
0.5 x is and i'm doing this just so i
can pick this
we want this thing right over here to be
perfect squares
because if 0.5 x is a perfect square
then the square root of that is going to
be is going to be an integer so let's
say that 0.5 let's think about all of
the perfect squares we could start with
well we could start with 0 then we could
go to 1 then we could go to
let's see 2 isn't a perfect square 3
isn't a perfect square i'm just thinking
of all the values that if i took the
square root i get an integer
and then i go to 4 then i go to
9
then i go to 16 then i go to 25. these
are the first these are definitely the
first five perfect squares and obviously
0 you take the principal squared of that
you get 0. so these would be good values
for 0.5 x but if those are what .5 x is
equal to what is x going to be
so if 0.5 x is 0 then x is also going to
be 0. you could solve it separately an
equation right over here you could say 0
0.5 x is equal to 0 x is equal to 0
divided by 0.5 just divide both sides by
0.5 and you get that equal to 0. so in
general to get what the x value is we
just have to take this number and divide
it by 0.5 or another way to think about
it take this number and multiply it by
two so when point five x is one that
means x is two right point five times
two is one point five times eight is
four point five times eighteen is 9. 0.5
times 32 is 16 0.5 times 50
is 25. so these are the x's we're going
to pick and once again i picked them
just so that this part of the expression
this part of the function definition
comes out cleanly
and now let's figure out what f of x is
at those values
so
f of
f of 0 is going to be equal to the
square root of 0.5 times
0 let me make my radical a little bit
bigger
0.5 times 0
minus 1. well this part right over here
is just 0. 0 minus 1 is just going to be
equal to
negative 1. now let's try it when x is
equal to 2.
f of 2 is going to be equal to the
square root of 0.5 times 2
minus 1. we already know that this part
right over here is equal to 1. so you
have one minus one is equal to zero
now let's do the next one
f of four
i've already used that blue color i'll
use green
f of four
f of four is equal to
0.5
times 4
times 4 minus 1. so this is we already
know sorry 0.5 times 8
that we're not taking f 4. we're taking
f of 8. let me be careful this is what
the x values are so f of 8
f of 8 is equal to 0.5
0.5 times 8 minus 1. this part right
over here will evaluate to so 0.5 times
eight is four you take the square root
the principal root of four you get two
two minus one is equal to
is equal to one
then over here we'd wanna do i'll do
this in pink f of 18.
f of 18 is square root of
0.5 times 18 0.5 times 18
minus 1. 0.5 times 18 is 9. you take the
square root of that you get 3 3 minus 1
is equal to 2. we'll do a couple more
f of 32
f of 32 is equal to
0.5 i'll say 0.5 times 32 minus 1 so
it's square root of 16 minus 1 so that's
4 minus 1 the principal root of 16 which
is 4 minus 1 which is equal to
3
and then finally do one more of these
f of 50
is equal to the square root of 0.5 times
50. 0.5 times 50 is just 25 and we take
the square root so this whole thing is
going to evaluate to 5.
5 minus 1 is equal to
is equal to 4. so we've taken some x's
in our domain and it's very important to
realize here that our domain is
restricted it is not all real numbers
and the reason why it is restricted is
if we're going to take the principal
root
right for the sake of this if we don't
go into you know things like imaginary
numbers and don't worry about that if
you don't know what those are
we have to assume that what's underneath
the radical sign is positive in order
for that to be positive x has to be
positive so in order for 0.5 x to be
greater than or equal to 0 which is what
the principal root is defined over for
for our purposes in this video then if
you divide both sides of this inequality
by 0.5 you say that x has got to be
equal greater than or equal to zero so
we sampled some points in the domain the
domain is all real numbers all real all
x's are all real numbers greater than or
equal to zero we've sampled some points
there we've strategically picked them so
that we get nice clean answers for f x
but now that we've figured out what f of
x is at each of these points we're ready
to plot
so let's let me draw some axes here
if we draw some axes so that's our
x-axis
and let's make this our y-axis
our y-axis
and i'll say y is equal to f of x
so whatever f of whatever f of x we get
for given x we're going to set that
equal to y and plot it on the vertical
axis
this is our x-axis right over there and
let's go point-by-point well actually
first let me draw the scale so the
x-axis goes all the way to 50. so let me
divide this so let's say that this is 10
this is 20
this is 30
this is 40 and this is 50.
and then our y-axis we're going to have
to go between negative 1 and 4. so let's
make this negative 1.
let's make that 1
2
3
and 4. and now we're ready to plot all
the points
so when x is equal to 0
when x is equal to 0
y or f of x is negative 1. so you have
the point zero negative one zero
which is right over there zero negative
one so let me actually this right over
here is zero
but we wanna plot the point zero
negative one it's going to sit right
over there let me give us coordinates
that is 0
negative 1.
then we plot 2 comma 0.
so 2 is going to be right
is going to be right around so this is
that is five two is going to be right
around there two comma zero is going to
be right there so that point right over
there is two comma zero in magenta
now we go to
now we go to eight
let me switch to that same green color
we go to eight comma one
eight is going to be right around here
we go one in the vertical direction gets
us right about there that is the point
eight comma one
then we go
in this in this pink color to 18 comma
2. when x is 18 f of x is 2. when x is
18 18 gets us right about there
when x is 18 f of x is equal to 2. so
that puts us right about there so that
is 18 comma 2.
then what's our next color we use orange
then then we have 32 comma 3 where f of
x of 30 f of 32 is 3. so 32 is right
about there
and f of 32 is 3. so it gets us right
right there so that is the point 32
comma 3.
and then we have the last sample of our
domain which is x is 50 and f of 50 is
4.
x is 50 f of 50 is 4. so i'll put it
right over there so this is the point
this is the point 50 comma 4. and now we
can connect the dots to get the graph of
the function i'll do that in white so if
i connect the dots i get a curve
that looks like
half of a sideways parabola and that's
essentially what it is so my curve
will look something like this it's
important to realize that the graph of
the function isn't just these points
it's actually any of these points so if
i were to pick an arbitrary x value to
the domain remember the x values the
domain here is x is greater than or
equal to zero or any real number greater
than or equal to zero so if i put pick
anything on the x on the x-axis that is
greater than or equal to 0 that's in the
domain and then if i evaluated its
function it should sit on that curve it
should sit on that curve that i just
drew